the u.s. women's national soccer team
which two years ago was beaten 5-2 by a
team of boys under the age of 15 has won
the World Cup or something we will
analyze with the rise of soccer means
for American politics then President
Trump parades tanks through DC a 2020
Democrat may be dropping out of the race
and Nancy Pelosi snipes at AOC all that
and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today the world of
sports has been rocked by the Women's
National Team and Megan Rapinoe but as
you know listen I am employed by The
Daily wire my show is hosted on The
Daily wire when we want to get to great
sports coverage we have to turn to our
sister network daily wire - and our
daily wire - sports correspondent Jeremy
the verified God King boring yes Michel
now with verified bold but not old
enormous news Michel from the world of
sports ball as for the second time in a
row America has proven conclusively that
our team is greater than all of the
women's soccer teams in the world and by
our team I mean the FC Dallas under 15
boys Academy a squad of 15 year old and
younger lads not quite athletic enough
to play football or baseball or even
basketball but who are nevertheless
better than the Americas national
women's team who in turn is better than
all the other women's national teams
from all the other nations who let women
play sports ball this Michael despite
the overwhelming pay disparity between
the female players who reportedly picked
up a quarter of a million dollars each
for the last game they won and the
scarcely pubescent male players whose
only compensation for their victory was
getting to skip third period for the
game and having a shot at the fourth
hottest girls in school those not quite
hot enough to date the high school
football or baseball or even basketball
players nevertheless as no average
teenage male was yet allowed in the
twice a year global tournament known as
the FIFA Women's World Cup America's
women's national team emerged victorious
in a competition handily defeating
Holland a nation literally filled with
such they won by a score Michael of 2-0
the pride of America celebrated their
win by trampling the flag of the nation
they were being paid to represent
during a cute little girl dance and
bitching incessantly about how they
aren't paid at the same as men to do the
exact same job completely missing the
point
that their job is not in fact to kick a
sports ball but to generate revenue in
the form of ticket sales merchandise and
TV licensing rights which they do not do
international media was quick to provide
context for the woman's nagging by
finding out that men and women are
exactly the same because men are famous
for nagging the media also completely
ignored the fact that the men's world
cup generates a literal order of
magnitude more money than the women's
sport because and I swear I'm not making
this up Michael there is a sport people
care less about than men's soccer the
media did stick at the President Donald
Trump however reporting on how a group
of young people calling themselves
Americans despite clear on-camera
evidence that they were watching girls
play soccer in public in France we
rehearsing the US president after Team
USA's win Donald Trump is reported to
have responded by saying I'm gonna be
president for life and then drinking
from a daily wire leftist tears hot or
cold tumbler available to annual
subscribers at daily wired.com slash
subscribe
get yours now but Michael as if that's
not enough information about a sport
neither one of us knows anything about
there's more America's national men's
team also competed in a soccer match
this weekend the Gold Cup which I can
only assume is an even bigger deal than
the World Cup since it's gold
they lost however to America's southern
neighbor Mexico proving yet again that
this is a pathetic non sport game of
chance that in no way represents
national greatness and that we should in
fact build the wall on our southern
border immediately to keep our male
soccer players in this country where
they can't humiliate humiliate us abroad
by losing a child's game to a near
third-world narco-state build the wall
Michael build the wall build the wall
aza
Jeremy wasn't the Gold Cup played in
Chicago how the hell would I know
Michael I'm just a daily wire to sports
correspondent you know Jeremy just
fabulous coverage as always I can't wait
till the World Cup happens again next
year and we can do it all again you know
I have to admit that this was a subpar
performance on my part Michael which I
think is appropriate for a subpar sport
it turns out there's just not that much
funny to say about the Women's World Cup
you know I mean if there were I think
you would have found it but
unfortunately you along with the rest of
the world could find no humor
that's boring yowza great coverage as
always from Jeremy the now verified God
King boring this is now I know that
Jeremy actually is Jeremy I know listen
I read my tweets I get the email I know
that some conservatives like soccer but
you shouldn't I know
hear me out this is what I'm not saying
just hear me out beyond the jokes beyond
the daily wire to sports coverage hear
me out as to why soccer actually is
anti-american because even if soccer
theoretically could be a good sport and
I'm willing to grant that theoretically
there's some universe in which soccer
could be sort of a watchable sport in
practice soccer is anti-american how
much more evidence of it do you need
just from this last version of it this
last run through the Women's World Cup
the captain of the American women's team
repeatedly consistently disrespected the
flag then one of the players Ally long
dropped the flag on the ground so that
she could dance around it mug for the
cameras then a bunch of American soccer
fans started chanting F Trump after the
victory on Fox News here they are we are
hardly own beer in the sport we were
looking at
but in that game canceled by the
officials because they were worried
about security measures so the American
fans here they came in from that
location over to this sports bar and
it's been a great crazy time here
watching history being made
that's how the Americans were
celebrating their national team's
victory abroad and regardless of your
political party regardless of what
sports you like you wouldn't see that
kind of thing in baseball or football or
basketball but that's not all they said
well get to what they said in a second
we'll get to the key difference between
soccer and other sports but first let me
tell you about one of the coolest
products I've ever seen this is paint
your life calm if you want to give a
truly meaningful gift you've got to try
paint your life calm so I saw this this
sponsor and I said that looks pretty
cool but I'm a little skeptical of it
and practice the idea is if you have an
original yourself you know your kids
your dog your a nice place that you like
to go you send the photo in and you can
pick out which painter you want which
artist you want on their website and you
will get a full original hand-painted
painting and the oil painting is what I
got from paint your life con and I just
was skeptical because I thought how good
can the painting be um there's no way
you just send in this photo and in a
couple weeks you get this painting back
there's no way it's gonna be any good I
am here to tell you I sent in a pretty
complex painting of my step-brother and
my stepsister in law and their wedding
day and it was in Grand Central so it's
kind of a difficult place to paint when
this thing came back I could not believe
what a beautiful work of art it is and
for a price that is shocking it is
shocking how inexpensive it is to get a
beautiful handcrafted work of art from
any picture that you want to have
painted I am now using this service
repeatedly already for Christmas
presents I just love this thing it's
unbelievable it is the perfect gift for
birthdays and anniversaries I mean I
always struggle to pick out gifts for
someone euro you get the new tech gadget
oh you get the new whatever
this is so cool it is one-of-a-kind I've
never seen anything like it
get yours now especially if you like the
artist I mean I love the artist who did
the last one I did so I'm just gonna
keep hiring that person again and again
there is no risk you are working with
this artist all along the way they send
you proofs if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded it is
great for decor it is a work of art with
paint your life you get your favorite
memories transformed into a work of art
that will be cherished forever you can
give it to your kids to your grandkids
it is unbelievable it's a great gift for
someone you love or frankly it's a great
gift just for yourself right now is a
limited time offer you can get 30% off
your painting you are not gonna get that
anywhere else
30% off and free shipping I cannot
possibly speak highly enough of this
product it is just incredible and if
you're one of my relatives or close
friends you're gonna get one at
Christmas probably to get this special
offer text Knowles right now 2 for 8 for
8 for 8 that is Noel's Kenna wles - 48
48 48 KN o wles - 48 48 48 message and
data rates may apply so you had these
American quote unquote soccer fans in in
France and they were cheering F Trump F
Trump I don't care who the president is
I don't care what political party you're
in you don't do that at a sports game
were theoretically at least you're
supposed to be supporting your country
the sports have always been patriotic
that's what sports are in part for and
this is especially true when you're
overseas but that's not all that they
said here's what some of these fans were
telling to reporters after the Americans
want
hurry it's gotta come from the
population you hear that this guy hates
his president he hates the people who
voted for the president he hates half of
his country I don't care if it's Obama I
don't care if it's Trump you don't hear
at a baseball game F Trump or F Obama
you don't hear F Trump you shouldn't at
least but it's soccer you do why why
does this so consistently go on wrong
why is it that left wingers in
particular like that guy why do they
love soccer in particular the problem is
in soccer itself just hear me out a few
reasons one because individual
achievement matters very little in
soccer very little in soccer actually
happens it's not a terribly interesting
game but that's not even the point I'm
willing to grant that baseball is not
always the most enthralling game I mean
if you're paying attention to what's
happening it is but it can be slow and
soccer is very slow too but at least in
baseball there are breakout performances
individual achievement is paramount in
soccer there very few breakout
performances there are very few goals
very often soccer games will end in ties
for people who don't like to see
individual achievement for people who
want us all to be in it together and not
to make anyone special and no everyone
gets a participation trophy soccer is
much more welcoming to that point of
view why else does the left like soccer
so much because soccer is foreign now
this is largely why the left loves it
because it's a favorite sport of people
who study abroad and then they come home
with the fake accent it's a favorite
sport of people who when they're
overseas they say I'm embarrassed to be
American like that guy they say oh I'm
from New York I'm from DC I'm from LA
but I'm not American ooh they really
like soccer and this was true it's less
true now but it was her
five or ten years ago they love soccer
precisely because it's not American
because it's a foreign sport that we've
slowly adopted in recent years and that
that's one thing they really like about
it but even beyond it being foreign of
origin I mean there's plenty of foreign
origin things that we like and we make
American the reason the left loves
soccer is because it's about
internationalism it's a it's a sport
that anybody can play I mean in the
technical aspects of the sport it's
pretty lowest-common-denominator you
need a ball and you need two goals and
that's it
you need a dirt patch or a grass patch
or an open field everyone can play it
this is why it's an internationally
popular game and beyond that the highest
expression of soccer is not the
individual game at between New York and
Boston or between American cities or
American states the highest expression
of soccer is what we just saw at the
international level at the World Cup and
so in this way it's a little bit like
the opposite of baseball you know
baseball we have the World Series and
the World Series doesn't really involve
anyone else from the rest of the world
you had a couple teams in Canada maybe
but that's it the world series is just
an America because the u.s. says we're
the most important thing in the world
and we're gonna limit the world series
just to American teams because those are
the only teams that matter plus you know
like the Blue Jays or something but with
soccer soccer presents the United States
as just one nation among many it's like
the UN of sports the UN is a ridiculous
concept it's the concept that all
nations get a seat at the table and
we're all basically equal but that's
never been true in the history of the
world not all nations are equal not all
nations are equally important not all
nations are equally just the United
States is the leader of the world that's
how our sports portray us traditionally
but the left loves soccer because soccer
is an equalising sport sure there's
Spain
there's Kenya there's some country I've
never heard of and there's the United
States and we're all basically equal
baseball version is right the United
States is not just one nation among many
we are essentially different from every
other nation our unique founding or
unique history or unique development
makes us incomparable we are actually a
different nation this is what American
exceptionalism is it's not just American
chauvinism it's not just saying we're
the best all the time sometimes it says
that but that's not exclusively what it
is what American exceptionalism is is it
means that America is exceptional it's
an exception to the rule of Nations now
I understand that many people many
conservatives even played soccer as a
kid maybe they played soccer in college
or something I don't mean this as a
personal attack on you I did plenty of
things in college that I'm not proud of
all right maybe we'll do an episode on
that one day maybe not it's a family
program but you should not let your
nostalgia for playing something as a kid
or your feelings for it get in the way
of the facts about this sport because
one of the biggest issues I mean maybe
this is what it really gets down to is
that soccer as far as sports go is soft
and simple it's certainly softer and
it's certainly simpler than other sports
both mentally and physically and in
nation's sports reflect that nation
we've been talking now for a couple
weeks about how sports are patriotic
activities this has been true since
ancient Greece the nation's games
reflect something about the nation and
this is the fear I actually think I have
some objectivity on this because I don't
care about sports at all I don't have a
personal dog in this fight I like
baseball well enough you know I'm a
Yankee fan but I don't watch every game
of the season I mean if I'm in the cigar
bar and the game is on I'll watch it
I'll watch the postseason or when the
games start to really matter but even
that I'm not totally enthralled with and
I think my disinterest in sports
actually gives me some objectivity here
and some perspective more than if
someone is a die-hard fan of some team
or some sport I think that sometimes
skews their perspective
just consider historically speaking
which sports have been the most popular
in the US and what eras those sports
were popular in what those errors looked
like for the country look at boxing
boxing is mentally and physically
exhausting boxing may be the noblest
sport it is really a beautiful sport to
watch it is fully human it is really
gritty I mean it's just the extreme of
mental strategy and agility and of
course physical endurance when was
boxing popular in the United States the
popularity of boxing in the US peaked
between the 1920s and the 1950s that was
right at the time that we were
back-to-back world war champs that was
right at the time that American industry
was exploding that was right at the time
that we were coming to dominate the
world we were an advancing nation and
our games and the games that we
preferred were reflecting that toughness
that grit those smarts but that just
total manliness
then what sport came after that to
become America's favorite national
pastime that was baseball baseball is
also mentally and physically demanding
not quite in the same way as boxing
they're very different sports
what's mentally exhausting about boxing
is your gauging the other guy you're
seeing what he's gonna do you've got to
be really light on your feet so your
your brain is telling your body where to
go what what to hold had a strike in
baseball there's a zillion rules
there's the infield fly rule there are a
million different plays where train
tracking statistics all the time in
baseball now it's also physically
demanding again not in the same way
you're not getting punched in the face
unless you're batting against Roger
Clemens or something but you you've got
a lot of precision that's required of
you that you work it takes a keen
political or political physical
precision to pitch the ball properly to
know which pitch to throw to figure out
what sign you're getting from the
catcher to get it right in the strike
zone or maybe not maybe that again it
takes a lot of precision to bat you got
a 90 mile an hour fastball coming at you
takes a lot of physical precision same
thing with fielding you got to know
exactly regardless of what happens if
this guy goes there I'm gonna throw it
here if that guy's gonna be the cutoff
but he starts to run from third I've got
to throw at home it's very precise and
complex this was the most popular sport
among Americans from 1948 to 1960
according to various surveys
this was at precisely the moment after
the Second World War that we were
constructing the world order this was at
precisely the moment that we were
managing the entire world we were and we
were also stating off Soviet Communism
this is as new independence movements
are happening nationalist movements are
happening around the world we were
managing new Nations entering the system
of nation-states of managing
independence nurturing these movements
protecting them sometimes from excesses
and from threats highly precise time in
America highly technical time but still
still physically demanding then what
happened after the 1960s according to
all the surveys the top sport in America
became football football is highly
strategic football also requires brute
force since 1972 I think it is football
has been ranked the top American sport
and what do we see in our national
policy at that time we see a policy of
more or less brute force we see a more
Imperial foreign policy I think it was a
justified foreign policy in that we were
staving off Soviet expansionism but it
was a foreign policy certainly that was
less nuanced than we saw in the early
20th century or in the 19th century even
forget about the foreign field in
domestic politics you had a domestic
politics of brute force all of a sudden
you had violent clashes on the streets
people are assassinating presidents
people are holding professors hostage at
Cornell University
you had the left with its new mantra the
personal is the political the
obliteration of this important and
nuanced but but highly important
distinction between the personal realm
of personal relationships and behavior
in the public realm of politics before
that there was a sort of genteel time
when you could be friends with someone
at a different political point of view
ever since the 60s and 70s that has
become less and less popular because the
left has embraced that idea that the
political is personal and and political
differences have to lead to personal
differences in that air that's the Arab
identity politics as the era of the less
reasoned pas
tics now we have soccer on the rise what
does that say about the country it says
that now in 2019 the US likes things
that are simple that are safe and that
are foreign the country doesn't like
itself as much doesn't like its own
traditions as much we see this reflected
in a ton of public polling the
percentage of Americans now who say
they're extremely proud to be Americans
is plummeting and among Democrats and
the left who disproportionately like
soccer that number is at 22 percent who
say they're extremely proud to be
Americans they don't like it we had a
the last Democrat president Barack Obama
he didn't say I want America to live up
to her ideals that's not how he launched
his campaign in 2008 he said I want to
fundamentally transform America he liked
things that are different than the
American tradition
you got to obliterate some of the
American traditions in order to
fundamentally transform it that is not a
good sign
and it actually has very little to do
whether you personally like soccer where
you grew up playing soccer and I'm not
sure really that you can change very
much of it I mean people are gonna like
whatever sport they're gonna like but it
does reflect something about the country
I mean now what there are a lot of
people who don't even want to look at
boxing there are a lot of people who say
it's barbaric it's too awful to people's
heads or something even football we need
to put more padding on them even
baseball we need to make baseball we
need to change baseball we need to add
the the instant replay we need to change
aspects of the game that tells you
something about where we are now what's
interesting at this moment is at the
same time that you have the rise of
soccer you also have the rise of UFC
which is brutal I mean that's boxing
without any of the rules it's it's a
much more brute force activity well I
think what that shows you is when you've
got two very different sports both on
the rise at the same time you're seeing
a polarization of the country and this
is reflected in our politics it's
reflected in electoral patterns and
public opinion surveys the Conservatives
are getting more conservative the
leftists are getting more left-wing and
the nation is coming apart and when a
nation doesn't have a
sports when we can't all share together
in our sports that to reflect something
about the nation which is that we don't
have very much that we can share at all
when you've got the captain of the
American national team the women's
soccer team who is supposed to be
representing the nation on a foreign
field when you have her criticized
viciously criticizing the American
president and worse than that protesting
the American flag the symbol of the
country itself you've lost something
you've if you can't even agree that you
like the country we don't have very much
in common anymore that's a great fear
and it's why this is actually why
conservatives hate soccer I know that
some conservatives might like soccer but
that's because I think they they like it
in a personal way I don't think any
conservatives like soccer ideologically
but that's why sometimes it requires
someone who doesn't care for sports
generally to look in and say what do the
sports tell us about the country this is
not a good sign but this is the good
news all hope is not lost because
president Trump had his tank filled
fourth of July parade and it was a great
success here as president Trump giving
the introduction to his really quite
quite excellent speech from the parade
the first lady and I wish each and every
one of you a happy Independence Day on
this truly historic 4th of July today we
come together as one nation with this
very special salute to America we
celebrate our history our people and the
heroes who proudly defend our flag the
brave men and women of the United States
military the Army Navy Air Force Coast
Guard Marines and very soon the space
force I want you to know that we're
going to be back in the moon very soon
and someday soon we will plant the
American flag on Mars
happening G it's happening Americans
love our freedom and no one will ever
take it away from us
we love our freedom we love being an
underdog we like seeing all the odds
against us and we say you're not gonna
take it away that's what independence
day is all about you know people called
Trump a narcissist and obviously puts
his name on everything he brags a lot
this was the least narcissistic
political speech presidential speech
certainly that I've seen in recent
memory this speech was actually all
about America about what makes America
America that how to make America great
again and it wasn't only about the past
it wasn't only about nostalgia
they say nostalgia is history after a
few drinks it was about really engaging
with our past while the left wants to
erase our past Trump was really engaging
with it because our past tells us about
our future the way that we understand
our past the way that we relate to our
past is going to tell us how we're going
to move our country into the future he
gets to that and with a great show of
strength which we'll get to in a second
but first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube and really really
awful news coming out of the Democratic
2020 primary it seems that one of our
favorite candidates may already be
dropping out of the race we will
celebrate that candidates wonderful in
hilarious contributions to 2020 then we
will get to the snipe fight between AOC
and Nancy Pelosi but you got to go to
daily wire comm ten bucks a month $100
for annual membership you get me you get
the inter Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you test questions in the mailbag you
get another Kingdom you get to ask
questions backstage you get everything
most importantly you get the leftist
ears tumblr now if you didn't have the
leftist ears tumblr on the fourth of
July as the tanks were going down in DC
you're you're probably no longer with us
so you have my prayers and your family I
send them condolences all the rest of
you get another tumblr you're gonna need
even more go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back
so after talking about what makes
America America President Trump then
moves into a show of American strength
celebrating what the tanks represent the
tanks aren't just blunt force they
represent our military they're a symbol
of our military and a tool of our
military and all the great men and women
who fight for our liberties and our
political traditions and our way of life
so that we don't have to so we can
continue to have it and he did it
beautifully is our incredible Airmen
today who will the most powerful weapon
systems on the planet earth for over 65
years no enemy Air Force has managed to
kill a single American soldier because
the skies belong to the United States of
America no enemy has attacked our people
without being met by a roar of thunder
and the awesome might of those who bid
farewell to earth and soar into the wild
blue yonder beautiful I mean that when
was the last time you heard that phrase
off we go into the wild blue yonder it's
like something you might have heard 20
years ago but politicians don't talk
about it anymore and Trump did and it
serves a real strategic purpose what it
is is a defiance of those who would do
us harm this is why this wasn't a
gratuitous parade I mean this was why it
wasn't even just a sort of nationally
indulgent parade we're sending a message
don't mess with us this is why FDR had
tanks at his inauguration it's why
Eisenhower had tanks it's why JFK had a
big fat nuclear weapon
big fat missile on his tanks at his
inauguration because we want to tell
people that we are prepared for war
every lesson of history tells us that
the way to ensure peace is to prepare
for war and this seems ironic but
weakness invites aggression if you don't
show that you are ready to turn the
aggressor nation into pure glass then
you are inviting their aggression we
don't want to use them president Trump
has been
basically the most peaceful president in
my lifetime I think certainly the most
peaceful president in my lifetime but
why is it it's because in part he's
built up the American military he's
unpredictable on the foreign front and
so the the would be aggressors don't
want to aggress too much but it's not
just about the tanks the tanks the
strength or great historical feats show
us the relationship between our past and
our future here's President Roh as long
as we stay true to our cause as long as
we remember our great history as long as
we never ever stop fighting for a better
future then there will be nothing that
America can not do
[Applause]
this was Reaganesque I mean this was a
speech you could easily hear coming out
of Reagan's mouth Trump is not exactly
like Reagan
he's like the 2019 reality TV version of
Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan came from a
more genteel time but his speech was
Reaganesque and it it was about the
future
it's what the left doesn't understand
when you talk about the past you don't
have to just leave it in the past you
can use it to show away to our future
and listen to how that speech ended you
know you have to ostensibly patriotic
events the u.s. women's national soccer
team winning the World Cup and this
fourth of July parade they're both
supposed to be patriotic celebrations
and at one you hear USA USA that's at
the Trump parade that the 4th of July
parade at the other one here F Trump F
Trump I'm embarrassed to be an American
that's patriotism that's been perverted
it's the opposite of patriotism this 4th
of July parade was a huge success I hope
we do it every year because the reason
the left opposed it a lot by the way is
that there were these two studies that
came out about seven or eight years ago
one out of Harvard the other I forget
where and and the Harvard one showed
that if you attend 4th of July parades
as a kid you are much more likely to
vote Republican later in your life
there's something about having a memory
a nostalgia of a childhood delight of
love for your country it makes you more
conservative we see if you love your
country more you're going to be more
conservative if you don't like your
country then you're gonna want to
fundamentally transform it like Barack
Obama said there was another study that
showed that even just looking at the
American flag a single exposure made you
more likely to identify as a
conservative and the effects lasted for
eight months which is why from a
tactical point of view that's why colin
kaepernick doesn't want the Betsy Ross
flag on the shoes it's why the left is
now trying to turn the symbol of our
country into a hate symbol because they
want to portray American history
American character the American essence
is something hateful and awful and
bigoted and terrible that we have to
totally do away with and transform so
that we can have their utopian solutions
that's the difference you got to pick a
side you've got it you've got to pick
the side of your country and seemingly
trivial things like a sneakers or a flag
waving or a parade or sports you like or
whatever the team you support these
things seem trivial but they make up the
culture and what we know from Andrew
Breitbart the patron saint of Hollywood
conservatives is that politics comes
from the culture it's downstream of
culture and if we have a culture that
hates the country we're gonna have a
politics that hates the country too that
undoes so much of what we love about
this country now we've got really bad
news on the political front turning to
the 2020 race this made is it may be a
breaking story might be happening right
now
there are news reports that Eric's wall
well
maybe dropping out of the race and this
is especially disappointing because Alex
Eric's well well assures me that he is
me and he is you and he is everybody so
it means we all dropped out of the race
350 million people dropping out of a
race is gonna seriously narrow it down a
300 was a 320 mm 230 million something
like that it's gonna really narrow it
down them the press release that came
out was it sois well to hold news
conference Monday campaign headquarters
2020 Democratic presidential candidate
congressman Eric swell well hold a news
conference Monday he just cancelled a
campaign swing through New Hampshire
he's currently not even registering on
the Rooker politics polling average of
the top 20 Democratic candidates he was
one of my favorite twenty twenty
Democrats not only because he was me but
because he's more a parody of a
presidential candidate than an actual
candidate you know he launched his
campaign on television threatening to
use nuclear weapons against lawful gun
owners he then stole the line from that
failed Delaware Senate candidate
Christine O'Donnell who was an accused
witch who made her campaign slogan IMU
that's what swoel stole before he goes
which inevitably he will do here is just
a quick trip down memory lane with Erics
wall well I will be bold without the
ball I've listened to some of my
colleagues mr. Glover tell you how much
they like your movies and I have to say
we didn't come here to talk about your
movies we came here to talk about your
activism
I like your activism I also like your
movies but I want to give you a chance
because I haven't heard the other side
other than tell you that they like them
they like that they like your movies
that they want to hear what you have to
say on this important issue the economy
is not the unemployment rate Donald
Trump was bold but a lot of what he was
bold
was just [ __ ] and the economy is not
the stock I've got just under $100,000
in student loan debt today go big be
bold do good when I'm not changing
diapers I'm changing Washington most the
time the diapers smell better
well white guy who doesn't see other
identities or understand other
experiences should not be President
I do and you know where there would be
gaps and my knowledge or my experience I
will pass the mic to people you know who
do have that experience it seems the
time to pass the mic has come
I hope the reports are not true maybe
he'll linger on another few weeks but in
any case Eric's wall well we hardly knew
you the question now is whether the race
will narrow very quickly obviously 320
million people dropping idea as a big
deal but the question is of the 25 or
remain er still in it will it narrow
very quickly or will people hang around
for a long time in 2016 Scott Walker got
out very early and virtually no one else
did so Scott Walker the Wisconsin
governor he was a leading candidate the
Koch brothers loved him I mean he was a
serious candidate very good governor and
his logic for getting out of that race
early was that all of the people who
weren't gonna win it needed to get out
to deny Trump the nomination because
Trump had this divide and conquer
strategy and he was going to get a
plurality of votes in all these
different states and then win the
nomination so my question for the
Democrats is how did that work out
Scott Walker dropped out nobody else
dropped out the thing Walker was trying
to prevent ultimately happened nobody is
motivated by altruism in presidential
politics
nobody ever it doesn't work if sois well
can't qualify for the debates then I
guess it makes sense for him to get out
because this campaign at that point is
is essentially over there's no way for
him to raise any money have a breakout
moment it's done
but for candidates who do qualify for
the debates they should stay in it as
long as possible as a kind of broader
thing for the whole Democratic Party it
would be better for the party if 22 of
them dropped out right now but for the
individual candidates it's not better
for any one of them to drop out right
now and because people are not motivated
by altruism Kamala Harris is not
motivated by helping Joe Biden get the
nomination there's really no reason for
them to do it no upside to getting out
no clear front-runner lots of
opportunity for publicity and
self-promotion which is all that half of
them are in it for anyway speaking of
useless presidential campaigns that are
only being used for shameless
self-promotion President Trump may get a
primary opponent or if not a primary
opponent a general election opponent who
was at least a Republican this is
congressman Justin Amash who announced
last Thursday that he's leaving the GOP
Amash is the congressman who called for
Trump's impeachment so the Democrats and
all of a sudden have a strange new
respect for him he's not really a
Republican anyway I mean tech now he's
officially not a Republican but he never
really was he was a libertarian who
realizes that now he has no future in
the GOP and so he's leaving and what do
we do in American politics when you fail
you fail upwards and you run for
president so he's been signaling for a
while he might run and with Jake Tapper
over the weekend he's not ruling it out
what about the possibility of your
running for president as a libertarian
or some under some under some other
ticket I asked you about that a four or
five months ago and you didn't rule it
out is it possible you
run for president I still wouldn't rule
anything like that out I believe that I
have to use my skills my public
influence where it serves the country
best and I believe I have to defend the
Constitution which in whichever way
works best and if that means doing
something else then I do that but I feel
confident about running in my district I
feel a close tie to my community I feel
I care a lot about my community I want
to represent them in Congress when do
you think you'll make a decision about a
possible presidential run well it's it's
something people talk about all the time
it's not something that's right on my
radar right now so I couldn't tell you
okay so Justin Amash possibly getting
into the presidential race is about as
consequential as Eric's well well
possibly getting out of the presidential
race it just does nothing it means
nothing and I actually kind of like some
of Justin Amash as positions I actually
like many of Justin Amash as positions
he's pro-life good he's anti spending
good he's a D regulator good good on
healthcare okay I like all of those
things
he's also bad on a lot of issues he's
bad on the military he wants a weaker
military wants to defund it he's bad on
congressional redistricting he wants to
set up some Independent Commission to
deal with districting which is obviously
just empowering bureaucrats and taking
away our ability for self government's
naive at best and profoundly harmful at
worst he's weak on border security very
weak on border security is weak on drugs
he's completely weak on marriage he has
no idea about any anything in the
cultural arena and he is a bit weak on
other social issues as well Justin Amash
is a libertarian he's not a conservative
this is really not about Donald Trump
Trump kind of was the straw that broke
the camel's back for him because he
personally really doesn't like Donald
Trump but this is an issue more broadly
over the past several decades the GOP
has become a home for both conservatives
and libertarians conservatives and
libertarians have a lot in common but
they are different views of the world
and particularly the GOP is a home for
conservatives the conservatives have far
more influence than the
tyrians as well they should if justin
amash doesn't like that he's welcome to
leave as he's doing right now but he
should realize a slim slim minority of
Americans agree with Justin Amash ISM a
very slim minority of Americans are even
broad or even vaguely libertarian you
know the kind of fiscal conservative
social liberal idea the polls put it
somewhere around 4% no political party
can cater to that group and remain
viable I've had billionaires tell me
that the GOP should become socially
liberal and fiscally conservative and
we'd win every election at all of the
elite universities and elite parties and
in groups like that people always love
this say I'm fiscally conservative but
socially liberal I don't care anything
about the culture I don't really care
about the moral law but I want to keep
more of my money and they think because
they're in a bubble that this is a way
forward they think they're this is the
majority of America that believes in
this nobody does it's only elite people
so only these self-appointed inlayed
people who feel this way so justin amash
has made his principled decision that's
fine now Amash and his principles will
fade into political obscurity what this
shows us is that the big challenge to
trump is no challenge at all remember
they said Kasich was gonna run against
Trump that's never gonna happen nobody
cares
doesn't matter barely makes the news on
CNN there is relatively little division
among the GOP but there is lots of
division among Democrats and we saw this
over the weekend with a OC and Pelosi
sniping at each other
AOC tweeted out quote I don't believe it
was a good idea for Dems to blindly
trust the Trump administration when so
many kids have died in their custody
it's a huge mistake this administration
also refuses to hand over documents to
Congress on the whereabouts of families
people's lives are getting bargained and
for what this is this shot right a
Democrat congressional leadership right
at Pelosi was Pelosi say all these
people have their public whatever and
their twitter world but they didn't have
any
following therefore people and that's
how many votes they got she's talking
about the fresh faces she's talking
about
Ilhan Omar Rashida to leave AOC that's
who she's alluding to here and she says
they didn't get a lot of votes and
you're right what you're seeing is this
breakdown at the Democratic Party which
is a consequence of their moral universe
in the fantasy moral universe of the
left national borders are wrong America
is evil the flag is a symbol of
oppression rather than freedom men are
evil except when men are women because
gender is a social construct and all
races are wonderful except white people
who are really bad except race is also a
social construct and all sexual
preferences are to be celebrated except
for heterosexuality which doesn't even
exist in the first place and babies
should be murdered after they've been
born that's the fantasy moral universe
Democrats have had a fantasy moral
universe for decades it's not a OCS
fault JFK would quote George Bernard
Shaw's play and say some people see
things that are and asked why I dream
things that never were and ask why not
what he forgets to mention is this is
the voice of the serpent tempting Eve in
the garden the line he's quoting from
that Shaw play is about the Garden of
Eden it's called back to Methuselah it's
a perverse moral idea and the trouble
for the Democrats is no one in reality
actually believes that stuff they only
believe it on Twitter the fantasy world
Twitter is not real life I'm telling you
they've bought their own fantasies aoc
got old German e-boats AOC got to ensure
that she would get elected to Congress
she got 14 thousand votes
in the district how many registered
voters are there something like a
quarter of a million she only got 14,000
because she was in this primary no one
was voting the primary a small number of
people put her in once she got the
Democrat nomination she was guaranteed
to win the general she has no actual
constituency but she has 4.7 million
Twitter followers so she has no hard
political leverage she has lots of
social media clout that is what we're
seeing happen here the world of hard
core real-time politics and the Verte
the world of virtual politics and virtue
signaling we're seeing that play out at
the presidential level and currently as
you look at the policy positions of
every one of those candidates the hard
left fantasy world is winning on all of
these issues health care for illegal
aliens tax the world into oblivion
ninety-three trillion dollar spending
the Sun Monsters the biggest threat the
virtual fantasy world is winning bad
news for Democrats Pelosi sees it but
unfortunately I think for the Democrats
their primary voters do not works for me
we've got a lot more to get to but we'll
have to do it tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today the u.s. women's team
won the World Cup as maybe you heard now
they're saying they deserve equal pay
that they're underpaid they're paid less
than the men they should get equal pay
well that's actually an extremely absurd
claim and I'll talk about why and and in
fact if you look at the stats the stats
show that women and the women's team
women's soccer players in this country
are overpaid overpaid and I'll explain
why
also the media invented another
controversy another outrage in invented
outrage to try to make conservatives
look stupid this one has to do with the
Little Mermaid of all things and finally
if we have the right to an attorney
which we do then why don't we have the
right to a doctor seems like if you have
the right to one you should have the
right to them to the other but that's
not so and I'll explain why today on the
Matt Walsh show